JASON: We all know
that in the world
today there's a lot
of people in the world
and a lot of change happening.
And so there's not as
many outlets or tools
to be able to make
those voices accessible.
And so Adam and his
team have put together
a project which will try
to address that and give
a voice to the voiceless by
way of peer-to-peer networking.
And without further ado,
I'll let Adam take it away.
ADAM FISK: Thanks
so much, Jason.
So as Jason said, I'm going to
talk to you guys about Lantern.
Lantern's a tool for
bypassing censors
in countries that
censor the internet.
And it's funded through
a series of grants
primarily from the
State Department.
So total funding for Lantern
has been about $5 million
over the course of
the last 3 years.
And I'm really excited to be
here at Google, first of all
just because the engineering
talent on this campus
is so amazing.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about our organization
and how we approach things.
And I think that relates a
lot to the engineering talent
that we see here at Google.
So we're a nonprofit.
We're called Brave New Software.
And Brave New
Software's mission is
to use software to tackle
tough global problems.
So the first problem
we're trying to tackle
is this issue of censorship.
And to me, there's really sort
of a scarcity of really focused
engineering effort, sort of
directly on problems like this.
So I think Google itself clearly
has this sort of immense,
in some sense,
philanthropic effect.
You can do things with Google
like detect flu outbreaks
before the CDC is able
to detect flu outbreaks.
So just by virtue of making
the world's information so
much more accessible,
Google itself sort of serves
this incredible purpose.
So whether it's climate change,
or censorship, or poverty,
I think as engineers and with
the capabilities that we have,
we have some obligation to
sort of try to put forth effort
to really focus on
some of those problems.
And that's really what we're
doing at Brave New Software.
So when I think
about Lantern, to me
it really starts when
I was really young.
So this is a picture of me
when I was three or four.
And I grew up in a
family of people--
a family of parents--
who were really
focused on the green
building movement,
on using architecture to
create social change, really.
So at that point, the
green building movement
wasn't even really a movement.
It was just sort of a
couple of people with ideas.
But because of that upbringing,
I sort of came into this world
with that type of
thinking and that being
around sort of very
dedicated people
as an everyday part of my life.
So I think that
really impacted sort
of the way I approached the
world and the way we approach
software and problems at Lantern
and at Brave New Software.
So this is a shot of me.
I sort of consider
this the first version
of Lantern in some way.
So basically, my parents were
constantly inventing things.
And I, early on, sort of wanted
to be a part of the action.
So I somehow thought
it would be a good idea
to take a toilet paper
roll, the inner cardboard
tube from a toilet paper roll,
and pair it with a burned
out light bulb.
And to me, this was a flashlight
or a lantern of sorts.
But if you look
more closely, it's
really kind of sad
and just pathetic.
It's a just colossal
failure on all levels
and was completely
non-functional.
But this idea of just sort
of participating and building
things to make the
world a better place
was really a part of my
thinking from very early on.
So fast forward,
gosh, 18 years or so.
I was one of the sort of
core engineers on LimeWire.
So I did a lot of the raw
engineering work on LimeWire.
And that experience really
reinforced this idea
that small teams of people
can create a big impact
and can impact change.
So at LimeWire, we were
anywhere from about 5 people
to 12 people, so an
incredibly small group.
And between us,
and the team over
at BitTorrent with Bram
Cohen, and the team at eDonkey
with Jed McCaleb, we
came to account for,
as I think everyone in
this room knows, about 40%
of all internet traffic in
a very short period of time.
This was a small group
of people who were just
massively changing the
internet as we know it.
And the other aspect of
my experience at LimeWire
was that it just
had this component
of being massively
sort of decentralized.
So it was much
more decentralized
than other peer-to-peer
networks out there.
And that was interesting from
an engineering perspective
to some extent in
terms of not having
a single point of failure.
But to me, the more
interesting part about that
was really not having a
single point of control.
So how do we build networks
that sort of more closely
reflect the decentralized
nature of the internet itself?
So to me, that aspect
of peer-to-peer
was really interesting
and got me thinking, even
in those early
years, about how you
might be able to use those
architectures to get around
censors.
So there was a piece of
software called TriangleBoy
around the year 2000
that used peer-to-peer
to get around censors.
And it was more of an
experiment at that time,
but that made me first start
to think about how you might
use this stuff to
bypass censors.
So I think it was
2009-- oh, sorry.
Actually, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about just the
problem of censorship.
So to me, living
in this country,
it's very difficult
to understand
what it's like to
live with censorship.
So without being able to
access all the sites we want
to access every day, I
think it's just a challenge
to really understand
what it's like.
So this is just me
proxying my traffic
through a server
in Iran and trying
to go to Twitter and to YouTube.
And you see this
blocking page come up
that just lists other sites
that the government recommends
that you might want to go to
instead of Twitter or YouTube.
And if you do this for a
very short period of time,
it's amazing just how
sort of debilitating it
is to your everyday experience.
So you get an email
from someone with a link
and you can't watch it.
And so for me if I do this for
even as little as half an hour,
almost instantly, it's just
like incredibly frustrating
and I just can't
take it anymore.
And I have to turn off the
proxy to go back to sort of life
as we know it.
So literally, when I first
started work on Lantern,
I was just in the shower
one day and I was like, hey,
I think I'm going to actually
just start coding today.
So the first component
I started coding on
was LittleProxy, which
is just an HTTP proxy.
And for me, it's oftentimes
hard to really feel
like I fully understand
something until I code it.
So with even an HTTP
proxy, it's relatively
straightforward in a lot of
ways and on a conceptual level.
But I felt like I just
really wanted to code it.
First, I didn't feel like there
were any really good proxies
out there.
And I feel like I wanted to just
really sort of immerse myself
in it.
So even things
like HTTP CONNECT,
you know, like that's a kind
of an interesting HTTP method.
And it means you can tunnel
anything through HTTP CONNECT.
And so conceptually,
you think, oh, OK.
That makes sense.
But when you think
about it, it's
actually incredibly powerful.
You can tunnel absolutely
anything through HTTP CONNECT.
You can speak any protocol
you want to speak,
which is kind of a big deal.
And that's something
we take advantage
of in different ways in Lantern.
So the other reason
I bring this up
is just from a modularity
software engineering
perspective.
So LittleProxy is this
totally separate project, just
a straight HTTP proxy.
And at this point, it's
used all over the world.
So it's used at Red Hat.
It's used at Electronic Arts.
It's used at New Relic
and at small businesses
all across Eastern Europe in
particular for some reason.
But none of the people
using it have any idea
that it's also used
within Lantern.
So they're actually patching it
and improving it all the time
for their own purposes.
But they have no idea
that at the same time
they're testing and
improving Lantern itself.
So to me, that's how good sort
of open source and modularity
works, is if you build something
that's useful to people
more generally and
also useful to you.
Sorry, I think there was
some animation there.
So this is just a
shot of someone--
not a real person-- at
home running Lantern.
And the way Lantern works is
users in uncensored regions
can download and install
it on their computers.
And because you at home have
access to the open internet,
people can proxy through you
and themselves get access.
So it uses this
peer-to-peer model
that does a couple of things.
On one level, it really ramps
up the number of access points.
So we try to make it very easy
to run a new access point.
And it's literally, you
just download it, install it
on your machine,
and just run it.
So just through sheer
numbers, Lantern
tries to be much more
blocking-resistant than sort
of existing solutions out there.
So we're just making it much
easier to deploy new instances.
So this is a shot of a much
earlier version of the Lantern
user interface.
But one thing we try to
do in the user interface
itself is just
really give people
this sense of connection
to people around the world.
So we're trying to build this
just like citizen-run piece
of software that allows
people around the world,
no matter where they're
from, to directly connect.
So this is showing in
real time your connections
around the world.
And this is mock
data at this point.
I'll show you some
live data later on.
But this is an example of a
user connecting from Iran.
So one aspect of--
I want to dive
into some of the more detailed
engineering things that we do.
So blocking resistance is
really a core part of Lantern
and differentiates it.
Some of the ways we
do blocking resistance
differentiates it from certainly
Tor and from other tools
out there.
So we use this algorithm
called Kaleidoscope
to distribute
addresses of proxies.
So one big challenge
out there is,
how do you distribute the
addresses of proxy/access
points in such a way that people
on the network can discover
them but censors cannot?
So Kaleidoscope uses a
trust network to do that.
And basically, what Kaleidoscope
calls advertisements
for proxies sort of trickle
through the network,
first, along a random walk.
And basically, from that
point after, it just
uses the same random walk.
So it initially chooses a path
and then always uses that path.
And basically, the idea is that
if a censor joins the network,
they're not going
to learn about all
of the proxies that
are already there.
A new actor on the network can't
learn about all the existing
proxies.
They might learn
about new proxies,
but they won't learn
about existing proxies.
So that's one way that
Lantern stays unblocked.
The sort of key component
of that is again,
this goes back to this
peer-to-peer element.
So this trust network
component is useless
unless you're able to
connect peers directly.
Like if I trust an individual
other user on the network,
if that's just some
server out there,
it sort of breaks this
trust network model
because that's not associated
with an individual, at least
in the normal conception of it.
So the way we do peer-to-peer
in Lantern is using WebRTC.
And we're releasing
a new library
called Natty that
basically wraps up
the WebRTC
implementation in Chrome
and just releases it as a
separate library that anyone
can use as a standalone entity.
And I imagine most people
here are familiar with WebRTC.
But basically, it uses UDP to
traverse NATs between directly
between browsers.
We're using it not
within the browser,
but within Lantern
itself to create
that peer-to-peer connectivity.
So doing that over UDP has
some interesting properties.
So it just so happens
that particularly
over these long-distance links
that Lantern tends to deal with
between, say, China and
here in Mountain View,
TCP really doesn't
handle that well.
So it sees this
high-latency connection
and sees this high packet loss
and mistakes it for congestion,
essentially.
So it sort of settles on a
sub-optimized window size
that really slows
down the connection.
So by implementing custom
protocols over UDP,
we're able to really speed up
those high-latency connections
between uncensored regions
and censored regions.
And it sort of just so
happens that the best way
to traverse NATs and
firewalls is using UDP.
So it's sort of a
handy marriage there.
So I want to dive
into a little bit
sort of how we've released
this stuff over time
around the world.
So this is just a shot of
satellite dishes in Tehran.
So in Iran, it's illegal
to own a satellite dish.
But if you look at
the skyline of Tehran,
you see satellite
dishes everywhere.
So Lantern, in a lot of ways,
is similar to that in the sense
that it's very visible.
These satellite dishes are
very visible on these rooftops.
And Lantern, or really
any tool this type,
like Tor or anything else, is
very visible on the network.
If you're looking at all
the network packets passing
through the entire
country, you can
see that these
connections are unique,
or these users are using
the network in a unique way.
So Lantern is certainly
visible on the network
in that same sense.
And it's focused on
access in the same sense
that these satellite dishes
are focused on access.
So we don't really get into
anonymity certainly in the way
that Tor does, but
our primary focus
is staying unblocked
and providing access.
So in terms of the
satellite dishes,
this was sort of a milestone
moment in Lantern's history
last Decem-- or I guess
November actually--
when we went on a
satellite television
station called Manoto1.
So Manoto is the largest
TV station in Iran,
or largest satellite TV
station in Iran, and because
of that, the largest
station, period.
And this is just the
Lantern piece on Manoto.
And basically, in order to
facilitate this broadcast,
they asked us, hey,
can you open up
downloads to Lantern
from the website
as a part of this broadcast so
that we can announce this thing
and have people actually
able to download it?
Because prior to that, based
on that Kaleidoscope algorithm
we were talking about,
Lantern was invite-only.
So the only way to get
access to the network
was through your friends
already having access
and getting invited.
So we did that.
And to some extent, we
sort of broke our own rules
when we did that.
Basically, we allowed users,
when they came to our website,
to enter their email
address and we would just
automatically invite them.
And relatively quickly in
Iran, certainly the day
of this broadcast, a
fair number of people
started picking up on it.
But within hours in China,
social media in China
really started to pick up on it.
So we started getting far
more downloads from China
than from Iran within
that first 12 hours.
But the problem was
that we were, again,
sort of breaking our
own rules in terms
of blocking resistance.
And basically, about
four weeks later,
there was an article in the
"South China Morning Post"
describing this massive
growth of Lantern in China.
And then about a week after
that, Lantern was blocked.
So it seems like
that article really
focused the attention of the
Great Firewall, people working
on the Great Firewall, to
get them to block Lantern.
And at that point, because
we had sort of intentionally
broken our own rules,
it wasn't so surprising.
But at the same time, we wanted
to be able to release Lantern
just directly from the
website through open downloads
to allow anyone to access it.
So we had this sort of problem.
How do we release
this openly so we
can help more people
while at the same time
keeping it unblocked?
In that instance, it
actually turned out
that the way they
were blocking it
was not through
infiltration, but was
rather through fingerprinting
our traffic on the network.
So we were actually able to
fix that relatively quickly,
so to look really exactly
like Apache byte for byte.
Prior to that, we didn't look
like Apache byte for byte
over the network.
And changing that really
fixed that problem.
But in that window,
it was the case
that if you ran Lantern at home
on your home network, literally
your computer would
be blocked from China
within like an hour and a half.
So no traffic would be able to
flow to your machine from China
within about an hour and a half.
We fixed that
within about a week,
but we still had this problem
of how do you distribute Lantern
more broadly while
keeping it unblocked?
So what paths forward are there?
And what have we implemented?
So basically, there's this
thing called domain fronting.
It goes by a couple
of different names.
But really, the
promising strategies
all revolve around this
idea of collateral freedom,
so this idea of
strength of numbers.
This idea that the best
way to stay unblocked
is to somehow hide
in other things
that censors don't
want to block.
So you see that with
things like Amazon AWS.
Like Lantern and a couple of
other tools for a long time
were distributing all of
their installers on S3.
Because basically, if you
were accessing S3 over HTTPS,
the only way to block that
link is to block all of S3.
And we thought that
censors would never
take that step, especially
the Chinese and the Iranians
would never take that step.
But about two months
ago, they did.
So China essentially
blocked all of S3,
while sort of opening access
periodically to some data
centers.
But they blocked all
of S3 for the most part
and crippled not only Lantern,
but sort of untold sites
on the internet.
So in that case, they
were willing to accept
the collateral damage
associated with that blocking.
But another sort of I guess
more promising example
of this collateral
freedom thesis
is this idea of domain
fronting that I mentioned.
So with domain
fronting, basically you
can trick websites,
websites/CDNs,
into routing things
to places that they
weren't intended to be routed.
So I'm just going to
show you a quick example
of doing this over cURL.
So this is just going to be
a cURL call to Hacker News,
to news.ycombinator.com.
And basically, all we're doing
here is specifying a header.
In the host header,
specifying reddit.com.
And you're going to
see what happens here.
And note that it's HTTPS.
So we're making an SSL
connection to Hacker News,
specifying a host
header of reddit.com.
So you see that in the
result-- and we're just
grabbing for the
title in the HTML.
So you can see in the result,
it clearly returned Reddit.
So that's kind of interesting.
It returned a site that was not
specified in the original URL.
So from the perspective
of a censor watching this,
they'll see this connection to
news.ycombinator.com, this SSL
connection, but then at that
point everything's encrypted.
They don't see that HTTP
host header passing through,
and they don't see
that eventually this
is going to reddit.com.
So on the one hand, that's kind
of interesting in the sense
that you can imagine
instead of reddit.com--
I think Reddit is actually
unblocked, surprisingly,
pretty much everywhere
in the world.
But you can imagine that
being just some blocked site.
So you could go directly
to a blocked site.
Or you could imagine that
being a connection to one
of our servers.
So this is a diagram of what's
happening under the hood.
So if that's going to
not just another website
but one of our servers, our
servers can go anywhere.
So our proxies can send
traffic wherever they want.
So that's exactly what we do.
And this is David Fifield who's
a researcher over at Berkeley
who has been doing some
great work in this area.
So what I just described is
both implemented in Lantern
and is a pluggable
transport in Tor.
So this is a diagram
from David, who's
a volunteer on the Tor project.
But yeah.
So this demonstrates
using that little trick
to go to one of our
servers instead of
going to the
destination website.
So the neat thing
about this, in terms
of all this issue of how do
we enable open downloads,
is that all of a sudden, if the
IP address of a Lantern server
is blocked, it doesn't matter.
Because all the censor
sees is this SSL connection
to this other site.
And then we can send that
traffic wherever we want.
So in Lantern's case,
we send that traffic
not just to our servers.
Lantern is a hybrid
system where we
run some servers to
make sure that people's
quality of service is good.
But we send it also to peers.
So we're actually entering
peers in our DNS round robin
and using this domain
fronting technique
to get to those peers.
So in that host header, we're
specifying roundrobin.--
it's actually
[? roundrobin.getintum.org ?]
for who knows what reason.
But that's not actually entered
in DNS, but in this example,
is on CloudFlare's DNS.
So we're, in that host
header, sending you
to our DNS round robin
that is a mixture of peers
and our servers.
So that enabled us to
re-release these open downloads
while staying unblocked,
that little trick.
And one of the
goals behind Lantern
that I didn't really
mention, and one
of the goals with this
peer-to-peer component,
is scalability.
So we're really interested
in the peer-to-peer aspect
in terms of blocking
resistance, but also
in terms of scalability.
If 500 million people in China
all got on Lantern tomorrow,
or all started using censorship
circumvention tools tomorrow,
we'd have a big problem.
And you really
could not-- possibly
Google could accommodate
that type of traffic
for proxying that
number of people.
But sort of any normal
entity with lesser means
would not be able to do that
on a financially scalable way.
So this is a shot
of when we enabled
this peer-to-peer traffic
in our round robin of one
of our servers, the load
on one of our servers.
So you see as soon
as we enabled peers,
just the CPU just dropped
to almost nothing.
So with all of these
peers running Lantern
in the uncensored world acting
as these access points, all
of a sudden we
can build a system
that is financially scalable in
terms of solving this problem.
So this is just a shot of
me running Lantern at home.
So once we started releasing
this domain fronting technique,
if you just run Lantern
on your home machine,
you'll start to see
this traffic from all
over the world
coming through you.
So this is live traffic.
And this is when
we first started
to really push this out.
So actually, you'll see a lot
more traffic now if you run it.
But this is, to me, sort
of the exciting part,
is you all of a sudden sort of
feel this sense of connection
with people around the
world, and are actually
tangibly really solving
this problem of censorship,
and are actually giving
people access in real time.
I just tend to run Lantern in
with what we call Give mode
on my machine overnight.
And this one night
I just-- there
were some little glitch where
I went into Dev mode in Chrome.
And somehow, I think
there's basically
some bug in the
Lantern UI that made
it show all of the connections
throughout the entire night.
So I just took a
screenshot of that.
And you can see.
That's my computer
there in Los Angeles.
And you can just see all
of these people connecting
through me throughout the
night from all over the world.
And in some cases, obviously,
a lot of these connections
are not from censored regions.
And Lantern does that
for a couple of reasons.
So like, for example,
when it first runs,
we don't know where you are.
So we have to geolocate
you in some way.
And to do that, oftentimes we
have to tunnel that traffic.
So we don't know
if the geolocation
servers themselves are blocked.
So we'll tunnel that traffic
through Lantern as well.
But to me, this was a really
sort of gratifying moment.
Because the combination of just
being able to instantly help
out through running Lantern
on your home machine
and really demonstrating
the financial viability
of this model with peers really
taking the load off of those
servers was just a
super-exciting time.
And I guess with
Lantern down the road,
as we kind of move
forward, we're
really just pushing
it out much further.
And really are still honing
this domain fronting technique.
So there's a lot
of little quirks
to how this works in terms
of like if you have to tunnel
things through HTTP
post requests and tunnel
them back through get requests.
So it still is very
much a work in progress.
And we're definitely trying
to grow the Lantern team
and push it out much more
broadly around the world.
So yeah, we certainly could
use all the help we can get.
I know 20% time is maybe not
what it once was at Google,
but we could certainly
use all the help
we can get in terms of whether
it's engineering help or even
project management or
product management help.
So thanks so much for
your time, everyone,
and really appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: So what stops,
say, the Chinese government
from just running a whole
bunch of fake Lantern servers
and making the service unusable?
ADAM FISK: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So I think to me, the
key there is unusable.
So from our perspective,
if the Chinese government
wants to run a bunch of servers
that actually proxy access,
that's fine.
And if you think
about it, they already
see all the traffic coming
in now to the country.
So they have infinite visibility
into the network traffic.
So it's not as if
they're running
a server they necessarily
have more visibility.
So there's that aspect to it.
But then there's this aspect
of servers that don't work.
So what Lantern does
is it'll detect.
Does this server
allow TCP connections?
Does it actually return the
site that I requested it return?
And it'll take proxies out of
rotation if they don't work.
AUDIENCE: But it might
not be easy to detect
a poorly-behaving proxy.
Like what if they just
slow everything down a ton?
ADAM FISK: Yeah.
So certainly, to some
extent, that's an arms race.
Like a dedicated adversary
doing those types of things
would be challenging in
terms of-- things that
are easy to detect
are a proxy not
accepting incoming connections.
We require that a proxy always
accept incoming connections
within five seconds.
But things like it's
really slowing things down,
that's a bit harder to detect.
And currently on
Lantern, that would
be a pretty effective attack.
Down the road, we'll
start to do things
like just even for performance
reasons outside of attacks,
track the performance of proxies
in general so we can rank them.
We want to give you fast
service no matter what.
So we'll always try to
send you to a fast proxy.
Right now, we don't
really get into that.
But that's definitely
an interesting attack
on the network for sure.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if accepting
money from the State Department
affects the adoption?
ADAM FISK: That's
a good question.
Yeah, I mean, we
don't really know.
We don't really have a lot
of visibility into that.
This came up-- we did
an "Ask Me Anything,"
an "AMA," on Reddit and
this question came up.
And there's clearly
sort of comparisons
between the State
Department and the NSA.
And in responding
to that question,
I think this response
applies here, too.
I just was pointing out that the
branch of the State Department
that we work with is
the Bureau of Democracy,
Human Rights, and Labor.
So their entire mission is
to advocate for human rights
and freedom of speech
around the world.
So if you actually like
talk to these individuals
and get to know
these individuals,
they're just literally,
these like public servants
who are working
for much less money
than they would
otherwise be making
in like these terrible
offices in DC.
So really, those individuals
end up controlling this money.
And they are very
much like-minded
and have a very similar
mission to our own mission.
So it may well sort
of hurt adoption.
And we try to be as open
about that as possible.
But in terms of how much it
actually affects adoption,
that's unclear.
I think for the most part,
in our experience people
in censored regions
will use whatever works.
So if something works, they
don't, for the most part,
care why it works.
But I think it may
be more of an issue
for the uncensored regions than
it is for censored regions,
actually.
AUDIENCE: What kind of
anonymity does Lantern provide?
ADAM FISK: Really, very little.
So I mean, it's a one-hop proxy.
So there is some
degree of anonymity
that one-hop proxies provide.
But we basically just
try not to even get
into the anonymity game.
So we work pretty closely with
various people on the Tor team.
And if you really
need anonymity,
we would really recommend
that people just use Tor.
From my perspective,
I think that tackling
sort of really usable
tools that stay
unblocked while also
tackling anonymity
is just super,
super challenging.
So we're really focused on
just building a tool that stays
unblocked and provides
really useful access.
And yeah, if you're a political
activist in Iran or China,
or something like
that, we would really
recommend that you use
something like Tor, particularly
if you're nervous about things
that you're doing online.
AUDIENCE: I am
asking that question
because I come
from such a country
where once you're known,
you can go to jail.
ADAM FISK: Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: And bad things
can happen to you.
ADAM FISK: Yeah.
I think those issues
are interesting.
I think, to me, if you're a
political activist in a region,
it's to some extent the same as
being some political activist
who's actually potentially
doing illegal things in the US.
So things like running
Tor or running Lantern,
I think a lot of times just
the visibility on the network,
like the fact that you're
running these tools,
might be enough if
you're an activist
to give a regime an excuse
to go knocking on your door
and pick you up.
But I think in a lot of
cases that just visibility
on the network itself
is almost as much
of an issue as the anonymity.
Because if you think about if
you're running Lantern in China
and you're visiting some
website, if that website is not
in Iran-- or sorry,
did I say China?
I can't remember.
It's China, yeah.
If you're in China and visiting
a website that's not in China,
a censor is not going
to be able to see that.
So they're not going to
deanonymize you that way.
So if you're visiting a
website that's in China,
they'll be able to
deanonymize you.
But that's also an issue
with programs like Tor.
So the idea of anonymity is
I think much more granular
than we think of it as.
There's anonymity in
the face of a censor.
And there's anonymity
from a website.
And I think those
are very different
in different scenarios.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
the clients use a geolocation
mechanism.
So that makes me wonder if
in these binding to proxies,
in the random-walks,
and so on, there's
some kind of optimized
routing you're trying to do?
ADAM FISK: Right now, we
don't get into that too much.
But we are seeing, especially
with that domain fronting
technique that we've been doing,
that you're jumping through so
many servers that
the geography starts
to become a bit of an issue.
So with the peer-to-peer
stuff, we don't do that.
But we are starting to
look at that more with-- we
may actually start to look at
it with the peer-to-peer stuff
itself to try to really locate
proxies closer to CloudFlare
data centers, essentially.
Because with that domain
fronting technique,
at this point we're tunneling
through these CloudFlare data
centers.
So that's really the geography
that makes the most sense.
CloudFlare uses Anycast.
So in China, that tends
to be the CloudFlare data
center in Korea.
So really, we want
peers in Korea.
But at this point, partially
because of that trust network
aspect, we can't optimize
the peers too much.
But certainly, if you
have a lot of peers,
we would be able to potentially.
But over time, that's going to
be about a much bigger issue,
I think, because there's staying
unblocked and being somewhat
usable.
And then the sort of
next step is speed,
so making it as
fast as possible.
AUDIENCE: But then
the Chinese censor's
proxy would win, right?
ADAM FISK: That's true.
Yeah, so that's right.
But in that case, that's OK.
So there's latency and then
there's throughput, right?
So if they're throttling
the throughput,
then that's an issue.
If they're low
latency, that's great.
So we have to detect those
things independently.
AUDIENCE: I guess
I'm just trying
to get-- I wonder if there's
a fundamental trade-off
between performance optimization
and the obscurity of proxies?
ADAM FISK: Certainly,
if we sort of, again,
broke some of our own rules
in terms of the trust network
and chose proxies
that were faster,
regardless of whether or
not they were trusted,
I think that would be true.
And there might be attacks
there where if you-- certainly,
we assume the censors will
penetrate the trust network.
So if they are able to
penetrate the trust network,
then we would tend to
preference closer peers.
But again, I think
a lot of that stuff
comes down to Lantern
just detecting
how well these proxies
are actually working
and taking them out of rotation
if they're doing anything
at all sort of sub-optimally.
But yeah, I mean,
that line of attack
is definitely an
interesting one for sure.
AUDIENCE: Lantern has
tremendous potential for good.
But how do you prevent
malevolent use,
like systemic child
pornography distribution
using your services?
Do you see necessary
limits to this technology?
Are there abuse
reporting abilities?
ADAM FISK: There aren't abuse
reporting abilities right now.
I think that's an
excellent question.
The one thing I didn't
mention about Lantern
in terms of how it
works by default
is that it uses a whitelist.
So it uses a whitelist
of sites that it provides
access to that we
know are unblocked.
So child porn sites are not
on that list, for example.
And primarily, those
sites are newspapers
we all know and
blogs that we know
to be blocked in Iran and China.
So I guess in my experience just
releasing consumer software,
you can't overestimate
the laziness of users.
So like the defaults
make a huge difference.
So I actually think
that that whitelist
is a significant factor in terms
of mitigating against that.
The other thing that
we're looking at
is implementing safe
DNS on the Give mode
side, so on the uncensored side.
So allowing uncensored users
to essentially act as censors.
So to specify, OK, we
only want to allow sites
on the whitelist, for example.
Because users in
censored regions
can customize the whitelist.
They can add their
own sites that they
know to be blocked that
maybe we don't know about.
But we're strongly considering
allowing uncensored world users
to limit how much
customization they
will allow through
their computers.
So that's another factor.
Beyond that, I would
say to some extent,
a criminal who would
use Tor-- I mean, sorry,
use Lantern-- is a bad criminal.
So I think to some extent, a
more sophisticated criminal
would just use Tor.
Because Lantern doesn't provide
anonymity in those ways.
AUDIENCE: How big
is the network?
How many active monthly users?
ADAM FISK: Oh, gosh.
We've done a horrible job
of tracking active monthly.
It's about a thousand
at any one time.
AUDIENCE: Proxies?
ADAM FISK: A thousand
just users running.
So it's about 50/50.
Well, actually, it's changed
a little bit more recently.
I think it's maybe 60/40
censors to uncensored.
So it's a little more
censored world users
than uncensored at this point.
JASON: All right.
Well, thank you, Adam.
Really appreciate your coming
in and presenting the Lantern
project.
If anybody's interested in
getting in touch with Adam
about potentially participating
or taking part in it,
we can exchange information
after the tech talk.
ADAM FISK: Sounds good.
Thanks so much, Jason.
JASON: Yeah.
ADAM FISK: Appreciate it.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]